l'automobile et la tête ça fait deux
enfin ça c'était avant que tesla
n'arrive depuis les constructeurs se
sont rendus compte de l'énorme retard
qu'il avait maintenant chacun y va de
son expérience en bon passionné de
telles que je suis j'ai testé quelques
voitures connectées ford audi volkswagen
est bien évidemment tesla mais mg jamais
je crois d'ailleurs ne jamais avoir
approché un véhicule m j'aime ma vie on
a été invité par mg pour découvrir leur
nouveau véhicule électrique moi je suis
un mec de la tech l'automobile j'aime
bien mais je suis pas un spécialiste par
contre l'attaquant marqué c'est mon truc
aujourd'hui je vous emmène avec moi à la
découverte de la connectivité de mj
qu'est ce qu'il nous réserve est ce
qu'ils savent faire des voitures
connectées c'est ce qu'on va voir en
route pour l'aventuré
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est tourner la mg5 et la
mg5 elle est plutôt marrante si jamais
dit je me tester une ong save connais
pas particulièrement les voitures de mgm
et pourquoi pas vous avez deux écrans
c'est ce qui nous intéresse dans la tête
ici premiers écrans de 10,25 pouces ou
là des trucs à faire on va regarder ça
ensemble on allait se balader aura
d'ailleurs si ça marche bien et puis un
deuxième écran de 7 pouces qui est
devant nous plus là où je vais avoir ma
vitesse toutes les options essayer ça et
après l'idée de cette voiture c'est
qu'elle n'est pas trop cher on est quoi
27 mille et quelques rôles il ya un
modèle à 32000 plus haut de gamme à
36000 euros autant dire que pour les
trucs c'est pas un vrai mon cher parce
que les voitures et riz coûte beaucoup
plus cher par rapport aux voitures
thermiques donc m jeu nous propose une
électrique pas low cost nagle petite
option au moins on le voit quand on
vient ouvrir les voitures on a un petit
bouton à l'arrière c'est à ouvrir aux
scop c'est à vous le faire mais il se
fait pas automatiquement ils ont enlevé
des choses pour gagner en prix pour
gagner en compétitivité et ça c'est
plutôt pas mal ça ça va dans le sens du
consommateur après ça dépend si vous
voulez le full options mais ça il faudra
aller sur un autre modèle et surtout
dépensé beaucoup plus d'argent en toi
comme ça c'est assez mal
aux gens change mon iphone j'ai pris
beaucoup de si peu la tâche alors il
faut des prises alors je sais qu'à des
prises ici alors là il ya un truc qui
manque c'est qu'à patte de rechargement
sans fil ça sortait vachement bien ouais
c'est pour faire des économies qui nous
ont pas nier moi j'ai une prise usb c
est ici devant j'ai que deux prises usb
ou alors d'une aux autres autant dire
qu'ici ça ça m'intéresse pas des masses
mais j'ai des prises à l'arrière et ça
c'est intéressant que c'est un choix qui
est assez bizarre kpmg ici d'ailleurs
que c'est à dire deux prises pour la
connectivité j'ai une usb a comme à
l'avant et usb c'est la seule usb c'est
que j'ai ici dans le véhicule donc la
hâte en europe là je viens je me mets
dedans et me reste plus qu'à faire un
truc c'est prendre moncade et jeté
devant et avant tout se récupère mon
câble je prends je branche et là je vais
là alors c'est pas très grave il se met
en charge je peux le mettre dans les
porte gobelets je peux venir le mettre à
l'intérieur si je veux la messe je me
passais mon câble et ouais c'est pas ouf
par contre si je veux le mettre hors
attend ce que jacques a fait quand même
un peu long le faire courir et m voilà
donc là ils savent ce choix bizarre
d'avoir mis 2 usb à l'avant une usb à
l'arrière un seul ace b salariés et pas
un usb et un usb c'est à la banque je
sais pas j'ai du mal à comprendre assez
bizarre d'ailleurs rien en tout cas très
bête au fait de part hormis deux prises
usb sait à l'avancé que moi sur les
nouveaux iphone vous avez que des prises
en usb c'est plus en usb et la plupart
des smartphones aujourd'hui vont avoir
des embouts en usb c'est du moins tous
les nouveaux smartphones alors il en
reste encore certains en usb à qu'on
peut venir utiliser mecs sur les prises
que j'ai l avant pour nous un branché on
appelle car play ou android os c'est une
seule prise en usb ce qui fait que mon
iphone que j'ai acheté mais les quelques
balles et bien je peux pas l'utiliser
ici ou alors il me faut acheter un
adaptateur lightning usb ces contacts
pourquoi il n'y a pas de logique once et
ça c'est un truc qui marche pas et je
trouve ça dommage parce que c'est
vachement limitatif à lorient tout que
je peux bien faire c'est branché mon
smartphone en bluetooth et une connectés
et envoyer de la musique en bluetooth
c'est ce que je fais tout de suite donc
ça c'est cool mais c'est pas apple car
plaît pourquoi mg l'idée les bizarres il
me faudrait deux prises qu'on puisse
avoir ici pour pouvoir connecter apple
car pelé ou andré liautaud une usb usb
c'est comme ça on a choisi un nom pour
l'apa
[Musique]
l'écran central cdu 10,25 pouces et dali
ps s'est aussi retrouvé le coeur et la
collectivité les bonnes voitures on à la
navigation la musique en bluetooth ici
tout ce qui va être charge est ici un
raccourci pour avoir apple car play et
android auto alors minée je trouve pas
mal en dessous vous avez des petits
boutons raccourci pour venir dessous la
navigation on clique on arrive dessus on
s'y repère hockey est très rapide
ensuite c'est pareil ici la musique bon
j'ai ma musique l'interface est pas
complètement dingue néanmoins on se
retrouve assez facilement je passe très
rapidement la charge également qu'elle a
le déchargement pour venir brancher un
appareil qu'on peut venir recharger à
partir de son véhicule et je vous non
seulement quelques instants apple car
perdre une auto on passe et après vous
avez ensuite ici regardez up oublié sur
le côté et vous avez vos différents
paramètres sur le côté c'est des
raccourcis la navigation la musique le
téléphone ici les caméras à 360 degrés
autour de la voiture ok ça marche le
truc maintenant qui est intéressant
c'est ce qu'on a ici alors il ya un
petit premier traduction est marquée
stations de charge en fait c'est la
climatisation et la climatisation garder
au plat pouvait venir régler et lorsque
je mets la température à fond il marque
aiguë donc c'est pareil petit terrain
traduction mais rassurez vous dans votre
véhicule s'il vous intéresse vous aurez
pas cette erreur tu rates ça va être
corrigé extrêmement rapidement c'est
extrêmement minimaliste on comprend
cette europe là les sièges chauffants on
va les emmener parce qu'il fait déjà
très très chaud ici on retrouve d'autres
choses que je vous ai déjà montré le
téléphone bluetooth là on a les
paramètres sur le véhicule alors tout
cas je trouve un peu relou c'est que
défendre et puis voyez ça vient pas je
trouve que des fois c'est pas très
réactif sur cette partie là il n'y a pas
des masses de paramètres il y en a
quelques-uns et on va pas extrêmement
loin dessus bon est-ce que c'est grave
pas nécessairement regarder voyez ça
c'est un truc qui est un peu relou
peut-être y avoir une mise à jour qui va
venir corriger ça j'appuie ça veut pas
ça vient pas et parce que je roule pas
et que si c'est bon la vidéo si vous
voulez hop là voilà l'ong demande
d'insérer la disquette eu je pense que
c'est pareil hein c'est un projet de
traduction aussi une clé usb c'est vous
pouvez mettre pour venir enregistrer ce
qui se passe dans votre voiture les
différents réglages en fait ici c'est
très sommaire si vous voulez essayer
toujours l'idée cette voiture là c'est
le compromis ils ont vraiment fait des
choix il ya un compromis de tous les
côtés il ya des compromis de tous les
côtés regardez c'est pareil leçon au
lieu de mettre son cd petites bêtises
interface mais qui vont je pense être
corrigé on a quelques infos on va à
l'essentiel ici c'est vraiment le choix
global kpmg ici c'est devenir efficace
et a pas venir s'embêter alors y'a un
truc que je trouve un peu con c'est
qu'ici on va ils nous ont mis plein de
raccourcis pour la température ok pour
venir délivrer ok la clim hockey tout ça
on revient au démarrage on monte le son
on baisse le son mais il ya un truc que
je trouve qui est vachement vachement
dommage c'est qu'en fait ils nous ont
mis aucun bouton pour avoir le gps c'est
à dire que lorsque j'ai lancé à
paramètres et que je roule je voudrais
revenir sur mon gps rapidement hebinger
pas le bouton et ça c'est un peu con il
faut que je revienne ici et je reviens
mais voyez le bouton lapointe coup il
aurait vraiment tout son sens et il
existe pas
[Musique]
jan ove système qui est intéressant si
vous pouvez venir utiliser la batterie
de votre voiture pour venir recharger
j'en sais rien moi une trottinette
électrique rechargé alors je dirais un
téléphone non parce que vous avez les
prises usb c est s b à l'intérieur mais
pouvait venir une télé pour regonfler
par exemple regardez là qu'on peut venir
gonfler par exemple et bien un outil
matin donc on à l'accessoire qui est là
on a ici de la prise c'est de l'apc 16
tournant parce que c'est ce que vous
aurez chez vous et là vous avez ça alors
vous venez vous ouvrez la trappe elle se
trouve ici vous prenez hop vous tirez
vous n'avez plus qu'à prendre ça vous
l'insérer dans ensuite vous prenez votre
accessoire vous le branchez à
l'intérieur il ya juste une petite manip
à faire à l'intérieur de la voiture il
faut venir ici dans des chargements et
commencer à décharger ça veut dire ça va
prendre l'énergie de la batterie de
votre voiture pour la transférer à ce
que vous voulez donc vous choisissez
après ce que vous voulez conserver en
termes d'énergie est forcément se
voulait encore un peu d'énergie dans
votre voiture ça dépend ce que vous
allez venir charger face nous on veut le
faire un petit peu on veut conserver
aller au moins la moitié de la batterie
vous cliquez sur commencé à décharger et
l'énergie la transférer directement à
votre prise électrique à l'extérieur
alors on a la bonne vieille méthode
semble faite à la bouche comme ça
je pense pas soit vous utilisez le
gonfleur qui est là avec les différents
goûts quand je vais mettre dedans et je
bats ont saturé
on parcourt vous savez un peu de
patience pour montrer ce qu'on peut pas
tout avoir devant cette pause bien ça va
à la plage ou à la plage prenez patience
ça marche et une fois tout installer bon
bah voilà on est pas mal on peut boire
le café ou ce que vous voulez l'apéro
alors après on oublie pas danger on peut
se mettre dans des lieux assez insolite
et je te reconnais que c'est pas mal
autrefois qu'installation vous avez une
application connectée convenir piloter
votre voiture à distance alors pourrait
piloter vous n'allez pas la conduire
c'est pas un volant mais vous êtes quand
même pas mal de petits paramètres ils
sont intéressants pour venir des
dérouillées votre voiture très
facilement vous voyez où est-ce que vous
en êtes au niveau de la batterie et vous
pouvez également programmer la charge de
ces trucs qui est assez sympa lorsque
vous êtes par exemple sur une aire
d'autoroute et que vous voulez voir où
est ce que vous êtes au niveau de la
charge pour vous connecter directement
vos des véhicules vous voyez vous en
êtes vous avez pas besoin de galérer
pareil de la même manière au niveau de
la charge programmé ce qui est sympa
c'est que vous dites par exemple le soir
de 22h à 5h du matin tu vas te recharger
mais pas le reste du temps c'est par
mail à programmer et ça c'est plutôt
intéressant alors après il ya d'autres
qui sont assez cool peut trouver votre
voiture en cliquant juste là ça va venir
vous là géolocalisé mémoire le wifi
c'est la galère donc là vous avez un
plan vous voyez où est votre véhicule ou
que vous y rendant très facilement vous
avez un itinéraire directement vers
votre voiture vous pouvez la faire
klaxonner pour la repérer si vous êtes
dans un parking qui aime beaucoup de
voitures ça peut être aussi très
pratique vous pouvez venir piloter votre
clim tout ce qui va être désembuage
votre profil un truc qui est intéressant
c'est que votre smartphone fait office
de clé vous avez plus besoin de clé vous
arrive et à caen nous tous il la
reconnaît des verrous ça c'est pratique
bref vous avez les infos essentielles
pour venir piloter ici votre voiture à
distance et ça c'est assez pratique
alors forcément quand on parle d'une
voiture ici électrique avec plein de
capteurs ben vous avez plein de capteurs
tous les côtés vous allez avoir des
caméras vrai bon sens on sait ça va être
là notamment pour l'aide à la conduite
et ça c'est plutôt pratique alors il ya
eu un intérêt qu'on dit que je trouve
qu'à une vachement complète ici alors
vous avez le lane assist une jolie
petite ferrari salut à toi
[Musique]
électrique on a dit pam cherchait qu'à
thermique donc vous avez le lane assist
vous avez les anti collision bref tout
ce qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui sur une
voiture je dirais haut de gamme au
niveau de l'électrique c'est plutôt pas
mal maintenant y'a un truc je suis pas
trop fan c'est au niveau de l'avant je
trouve que salam tu vois c'est la partie
où on vient recharger notre véhicule
dans la recharge ici alors pourquoi pas
l'intégrer ici mais je trouve qu'au
final c'est pas forcément harmonieux
parce que là on a cette forme de logo
qui est déjà un peu cheap et ça nous
rajoute une autre forme pas dessus avec
la petite caméra en dessous en caméra
elle me dérange pas mais c'est parce
qu'on fait un truc qui marche pas ici là
au niveau des au niveau des formes ça me
plaît pas trop ce que j'aime bien par
contre sur le véhicule c'est quand on le
voit deux côtés comme on est sur un
break là de la gueule moi j'aime bien
les breaks inverse avec la mode c'est
plutôt le suv mais je trouve que là on
est quand même sur un break car
franchement de la gueule et alors ça
c'est marrant parce qu'on en a parlé
comme j ai aimé j'ai eus nous dit ouais
c'est vrai la mode c'est le suv tout le
monde veut des suv mais le break ça
marche encore ça marche pour le
particulier qui veut quand même un grand
coffre et qui veut du rangement et qui
veut de belles places assises ça marche
aussi pour des taxis qui ont besoin de
place pour mettre des bagages ça marche
également pour des commerciaux bref on
voit que c'est une voiture qui se
destine aussi bien aux particuliers
qu'aux professionnels et ça j'aime bien
ce côté là c'est le fond je trouve
plutôt cool les jantes également à
l'arrière franchement j'aime bien aussi
donc ça ça me prend l'argent ça vaudra
cas précis
[Musique]
on
juste devant bo vous avez un écran de 7
pouces alors et écran 7 pouces il est
assez pratique parce que vous avez des
informations de base attention vous
allez voir votre trajet en cours vous
allez avoir quoi hop là votre total
cumulé on va retrouver des infos au
niveau de la vitesse de l'entretien la
pression des pneus s'il ya des anomalies
vous avez aussi de la navigation ici et
c'est assez pratique boyer et puis après
on tourne en rond alors on va retrouver
sur le côté gauche la vitesse on à la
batterie on va le nombre de kilomètres
on peut faire et puis on a là la
récupération alors vous avez différents
modes je roule en mode confort vous avez
un mode eco vous avez également un mode
sport on va éviter ça va venir consommer
davantage et puis après récupération
d'énergie la cheville en confort un peu
passés en deux je peux passer en 3 c'est
pas du wan [ __ ] mais c'est quand même
pas mal ça permet de récupérer un petit
peu donc dans l'idée pourquoi pas
[Musique]
bon alors si on doit faire un bilan de
cette mjc 5 mois la mise et ça que je la
trouve sous le couvert intéressant parce
que c'est le fait de démocratiser je
trouve ça permet casser un peu les
prises électriques parce que les
voitures électriques versus les porteurs
thermique coûte vachement cher donc là
le fait de nous emmener une voiture
électrique aux alentours des 30 mille
trente deux mille euros et avec des
adaptations qu'on arrive aux alentours
de 27000 euros franchement c'est bien
donc ça c'est vachement cool et ça se
démocratise ça reste beaucoup d'argent
c'est clair mais bon voilà c'est comme
ça ça coûte cher aujourd'hui s'appelle
sera probablement à l'avenir ça en tout
cas ces points premier point le deuxième
point je trouve que en termes de
conduite avait plutôt agréable je vous
invite à aller voir la presse
spécialisée automobile qui vous parle
vraiment de conduits de confort de
conduite c'est plus ardemment c'est
vraiment la connectivité la tête je
reste un peu déçu par ce côté pas eu
prise usb s'est connecté pour apple car
pleyel avant je faisais un non sens là
dessus et c'est pas bon quoi
l'expérience je trouve assez minimaliste
au niveau de la connectivité mais j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut j'ai le minimum page
et ce qui me conviendra j'ai
effectivement j'ai dit apple care playes
android auto je vais avoir le fait de
pouvoir connecter mon smartphone en
bluetooth pour passer mes appels j'ai ma
navigation gma connectivité avec mon
application pour gérer mon véhicule je
peux mettre la température je peux
retrouver femme âgée tout ce qui me va
bien mon écran central avec mon compteur
est aussi plutôt bien réalisé sa
fonction de ça on a une très belle
voiture connectée ici ça ça me va bien
après l'idée qu'ils soient allés sur un
break versus s'en est suivie il en faut
de toute façon donc why not permet de
venir acheter un produit dans la gamme
donc ça c'est cool et puis en fait je
crois que c'est vraiment le truc que je
vais retenir sur 7 mg 5 c'est la notion
de compromis c'est vraiment des
compromis que sont venus faire mg ici on
voit les boutons sur la portière au
niveau du coffre c'est pareil c'est pas
les tricks c'est à vous de le faire ça
permet de baisser l'addition ça vous
permet de sortir un break 100%
électrique moins cher bon voilà après on
en a pour son argent ça reste beaucoup
d'argent c'est une évidence mais c'est
une belle voiture qui fonctionnera bien
et qui ira bien si vous voulez rentrer
dans l'électrique je vais pas dire par
la petite porte parce que c'est pas vrai
mais je dirais par le le côté plus
abordable même si 30000 euros ça reste
beaucoup d'argent mais c'est très cher
mais c'est comme ça aujourd'hui
automobiles électriques donc voilà pour
ce que je voulais vous dire aujourd'hui
sur ce ce véhicule alors une fois de
plus sans ici on parle de teck et que de
teck donc si vous voulez parler d'eux
les volumes de litres du coffre et par
les deux moteurs et tous à aller voir
les médias spécialisés si par contre
vous voulez qu'on continue à parler tech
automobile vous me dites dans les
commentaires et puis dites moi ce que
voudrait qu'on regarde conteste en
automobiles sont des choses qui vous
botte voilà un pays moi je continue à
prendre la route parce que là on est
dans les alpilles on est aux baux de
provence et c'est super beau voilà sans
faire de faux jeunes au boulot à bientôt
ciao